c'est dans ce lac qu'un enfant de 10 ans
s'est noyé la semaine dernière pourtant
le drame a eu lieu malgré la
surveillance d'un maître nageur et sous
la responsabilité de sa famille alors
comment enrayer ce fléau au bord de
cette autre plan d'eau les parents sont
vigilants ça va aller vite un accident
ça ça vient comme ça ça ne prévient pas
il ya toujours au moins un des deux
adultes qui a toujours un oeil quand
même pour regarder ce que les enfants
sont en train de faire donc il n'ya pas
de stress à quelques mètres de là
alors on est le moteur là à l'effort
pour finir fort engendre pour finir
quatre enfants apprennent à se
débrouiller dans l'eau au revoir malo au
revoir malo
acquérir les rudiments de la natation
améliorer sa pratique là je crois que tu
es pas partir en nageant surtout à tempe
et à étupes arena jean gagné en
confiance
cet exercice s'est effectivement les
habitués à tomber dans l'eau à un moment
où ils s'y attendent pas forcément et
être capable de s'orienter pour pouvoir
repartir vers le vers le port le plus
proche est effectivement atteindre la
rive à peine revenu à la surface pour
malo le message est passé
ban avait conduit pas
vous trouverez et sur la rive sa mère
semble plus sereine
il ya toujours une peur de la noyade
quel que soit l'environnement d'ailleurs
un piscine ou milieu naturel on est plus
rassuré quand il s'agit là j'ai mes bons
fous quand il peut y avoir des jeux
aussi
qui peuvent dégénérer donc faut toujours
avoir un oeil sur eux quand même une
surveillance d'autant plus indispensable
à la mer dans les lacs et les étangs
ici vous avez du vent vous avez des
agglos est beaucoup plus fraîche enfin
voila c'est il ya du vent enfin et oui c
est ce qui est sûr c'est qu'un enfant
qui sait nager en milieu naturel sera
nagé en piscine une averse n'est pas
toujours vrai en france la noyade est la
première cause de mortalité par accident
chez les jeunes de moins de 15 ans